[Music]
thank you
hello I'm Adrian Finnegan this is
counting the cost on Altus era you'll
look at the world of business and
economics this week Russia shuts off
Europe's main gas pipeline after the G7
countries agreed to cap the prices of
Russian oil and the EU plans to set a
limit on moscow's gas prices who is
winning the energy battle
also this week Europe's energy crisis
deepens as Russia tightens its Chokehold
on supplies the EU says it's prepared to
meet the challenge should Moscow turn
off the gas Taps but is it
and skyrocketing Energy prices are
squeezing people's incomes in rich and
poor countries alike when will global
inflation Peak or could the rising cost
of living remain far too hot
an all-out energy war between Russia and
the West threatens to deepen Europe's
energy crisis putting pressure on
governments to make interventions in the
energy Market to rein in soaring prices
but it also puts the kremlin's revenues
at risk that is meant to stem the flow
of funds into its War coffers moscow's
earnings from energy exports are
expected to rise by 38 this year Western
capitals say they want to cut off that
Financial Lifeline the G7 group the US
Japan Canada Germany France Italy and
the UK have agreed to cap the price of
Russian oil shortly after that decision
Russia's energy giant announced an
indefinite halt to gas flows to Europe
through the Nordstrom one gas pipeline
citing the need for additional repairs
gas prices surged more than 35 percent
the Euro slid to its lowest in two
decades as Moscow warned that it won't
reopen that pipeline until sanctions are
lifted and the EU is planning a cap on
Russian gas prices too among other
proposals to curb soaring energy costs
President Vladimir Putin has warned the
West that it cannot isolate Russia he
says that Western sanctions against
Moscow have backfired and now threatened
the whole world Al jazeera's Nadine
barber reports
a bold move from Brussels but will it
work the European commissions going
ahead with a plan for a new price cap on
Russian natural gas we all know that our
sanctions are deeply grinding into the
Russian economy with a heavy negative
impact
but Putin is partially buffering through
fossil fuel revenues so here the
objective is we must cut Russia's
revenues which Putin users to finance
his atrocious war in Ukraine since
February the eu's imposed sanctions on
Russia and acted to wean itself off
Russian energy some member states are
skeptical of the price cap worried it
could push Moscow to turn off the Taps
completely Russia's already stopped or
reduced supplies on three of its biggest
Westwood gas pipelines while oil
supplies have been redirected eastwards
as its economy of course is now more cut
off from the Western for many Global
markets than at any point since the end
of the Cold War and in some respects the
way that the war in Ukraine is gone and
Russian Russia's subjection to sanctions
means that Russia's economic fate is
sealed it has to become an asia-facing
Eastern facing economic power or it will
economically perish if President Putin's
worried he's not letting on speaking at
the Eastern economic Forum in
Vladivostok he called the price cap idea
stupid
he also addressed another issue with
global implications Ukraine's grain
exports shipments like this one resumed
after Kiev and Moscow reached a deal in
July with turkey and the United Nations
acting as guarantors but Putin says the
developing world is being cheated
if we remove turkey as an intermediary
virtually all the grain was brought not
to the poorest countries but to the
European Union the world food program
speaks of the need for the poorest
countries out of sixty thousand tons of
production just three percent went to
developing countries
U.N data shows turkey has been the
biggest single destination with cargos
also going to China India Egypt Yemen
Somalia and Djibouti whatever the
reality Vladimir Putin insists his
country's already seen off the worst
effects of Western sanctions saying
inflation has started to fall he told
this Gathering Russia's natural
resources would protect the nation as
jobs and companies disappeared in Europe
that's surely a warning that continent
can't ignore
joining us now David Beck the chief
Economist of london-based energy
intelligence provider vortexa he's in
Quito in Ecuador good to have you with
us uh David so the EU is planning this
cap on on gas prices among other
proposals is that going to help its
energy market so just simply raise the
stakes even further with Russia
yes
um the stakes with Russia are already
extremely high I would say the gas price
cap question is secondary to the oil
price cap question because the Atlanta
one is of global importance the former
one is primarily aggression for the
European Market at this point of time
there are also two aspects to this gas
price Capital One is simply the price of
this page to Russia for gas Imports But
ultimately the more important question
at this point of time is whether this
classical married order in power
generation is put out the force the
Merit order means that always the high
the most expensive power source will
Define the price of electricity and this
is now natural gas with a very small
share in the wall uh Power mix uh
basically leading to uh windfall a
massive windfall profits for the power
generation industry that is processing
the Renewables or coal or nuclear or
whatever okay um so these are the two
considerations of the European okay
we'll talk we'll talk about that how the
energy Market is is is priced a little
later in the program in the meantime you
mentioned that the cap on oil there is
that cap on oil price is going to work
and why does the West need that price
cap when European nations are trying to
phase out their Reliance upon Russian
oil in the first place
the oil price cap is basically not
needed that much from the European point
of view it's needed from the global
point of view because the question is
how much oil does Supply Russia to the
market uh and there is a insurance band
coming up on shipping oil uh to third
countries uh and that is a powerful pen
from the European Union
um and that is threatening basically to
cut off Russian Supply Russia is
actually struggling to place its barrels
in the market uh yes China and India are
buying more than they used to but pretty
much everybody else has stayed on the
sidelines due to the complexities and
that is as now there is even no actually
legal restriction in importing Russian
oil but the insurance ban will come up
in December or we will be fully
effective in December this year and that
is something that you could say is
actually forcing G7 at the European
Union in installing this price cap
because as part out of this price cap
this intro which band would be stopped
or Ended as you said China and India
could undermine uh the price cap Anyway
by continuing to buy Russian oil at
whatever price Russia charges how do you
go about then policing the this this G7
price cap on oil
yeah let me say first the verb uh on on
China and India I think it's also in
their interest I just looked up our data
uh in China and India have imported nine
percent of their oil from Russia before
the war started and now they're
importing 17 of their oil from Russia uh
so that means still 83 percent of the
oil is imported from other countries so
it's essential for those countries as
well that the oil price remains as low
as possible in the global oil price cap
would uh basically
um also incentivize Russia to export as
much as oil as possible because that
would then be the only level for income
yeah to raise production and exports
um so this is uh why it's in their
interest and ultimately you know every
buyer wants to buy as cheap as possible
and if there is a fixed price set
um in my opinion that would have to be
on a four basis so on a on a Russia
export basis uh and then there's still
all the a logistical costs to be paid
for China and India and any other place
in the world
um this yeah I mean there is simply a
very clear incentive for any any
consumer country if this reference price
is there then they will try to get as
close to it whether they may perhaps pay
a one dollar or two dollar or a five
dollar premium in some illicit ways uh
individual players that's not really of
relevance the important thing is whether
it's 50 or whether it's 100. on in a
speech on on Wednesday President Putin
threatened to cut off energy supplies
completely to uh to Europe
what happens if he does
yes the question is can he yeah uh
short-term answer yes of course should
he can do this uh for a week for a day
he can threaten with it uh can he do it
in the long term uh I'm speaking here of
months uh one month two months three
months I would say no I think it's
important to understand the
contributions of gas and oil to the
Russian budget the oil contribution is
about four times bigger than the gas
contribution so that's why they could
play the gas card with Europe uh but
they can in my opinion not play the oil
card on a persistent basis that they can
make troubles in the short term uh
that's very clear David it's really good
to talk to you on County the cost many
thanks indeed David veck there in Quito
in Ecuador
now Europe has accused Russia of using
energy as a weapon against those
supporting Ukraine the Kremlin blames
Western sanctions for pipeline shutdowns
Moscow has already stopped sending gas
to what it calls unfriendly European
nations because they refuse to pay in
Rubles Europe's leaders are now bracing
for the risk of a Russian gas cutoff and
are scrambling to find ways to cut
demand they've rapidly filled their gas
storage facilities and Country Stores
have exceeded the 80 Target that was set
to be reached by October some European
nations like Germany have also sought
alternative suppliers like liquefied
natural gas from the U.S and Qatar but
that's still a work in progress Norway
Europe's second biggest gas supplier
behind Russia is Raising production to
help the EU end its Reliance on Russian
fossil fuels by 2027. Algeria is also
among the countries looking to increase
supplies to European nations like Italy
and Spain European are voluntarily
reducing their gas consumption by 15
percent in an attempt to get through
winter and they're reactivating coal or
nuclear plants to fill the energy gap
While others are turning to electricity
Imports Renewables and hydropower
well to discuss all of this we're joined
by Simone Talia Pietra Simone is a
senior fellow at the brugel think tank
and a researcher on the eu's energy and
climate policies he joins us now from
Brussels Simone good to have you with us
now to what extent is the rising cost of
energy down not just to the war in
Ukraine but the crazy way in which the
energy markets operate the marginal
pricing system for electricity in which
as we heard earlier in the program the
highest price bid sets the overall price
and speculate us driving up the price of
gas on the ttf is it fair to say that
this is as much a crisis of badly
designed and obsolete institutions that
enrich a tiny few at the expense of
everyone else than it is about the war
well as a matter of fact the European
electricity Market design that you
described as functioned very well for a
long period of time
but this is a situation we are in which
is a war and it is a weaponization of
energy that has been done by Russia
which makes the current market setting
and fit for the Emergency we are in
so this is a market that functions
pretty well in peace time but we are not
in peacetime right now and this is the
reason why the European commission is
proposing not to overturn these Market
design in a rush because this is a
complex set of rules that is also very
important to provide the investment
certainty and the Foster investments in
Renewables namely in the coming years
but adopting emergency measures that
might take out part of those extra
profits that have been
done by the generators of electricity
with Renewables nuclear Etc in order to
use those resources for lowering the
energy bills of energy of energy
companies of companies families across
Europe so this is the kind of emergency
measures the commission proposes to do
without disrupting these electricity
Market design right now because it will
take time to rethink that and the that
will be done most likely next year
Europe's LNG Imports have have increased
how long though could it rely on
shipments I mean some countries don't
have the infrastructure even to take on
board uh LNG that's that's shipped uh to
to Europe and who are the winners
benefiting from this this current energy
crisis other than those as you said who
are earning huge profits right now
it is crystal clear that the real extra
profits now stand in the producing
countries so whoever is producing gas
and exporting it to Europe either via
pipeline or via LNG is now making a lot
of money and this is why we start to see
also conversations for example we have
recently seen an interview by the
Norwegian prime minister saying we are
aware of the difficult situation right
of Europe and the very high gas price we
we are open to discuss the price cups in
order to lower our own gas supplies to
to Europe the price of our own gas
supplies to Europe if we revise our
long-term contracts in such a manner so
I think there is a clear recognition
that some countries the gas producers
the oil producers are making a lot of
money in this moment and and this
certainly represents an international
let's say distributional issue Russia
also of course facing a a long cold
winter just how much have Western
sanctions against Russia hurt its
economy President Putin says that the
sanctions have backfired is is he right
or are the people of Russia going to
feel it hard this winter too
well the very reason that Moscow has
been rushing in closing North stream in
September rather than as many expected
in the winter might be a sign that
Russia wants to anticipate and escalates
before the pressure it can try to
escalate towards Europe because probably
sanctions are biting and we know very
well that the sanctions that have been
that have been put on Russia will
seriously compromise the Russian economy
in the middle long term
uh we know that without exporting its
energy to Europe Russia will end up
being a minor partner in our
relationship with China which will not
certainly be so convenient for the
Russian people
and I think we are better aware of these
timing Dimension it's true in the short
term it's Europe that will suffer and is
suffering because of the high energy
prices but Europe is proving its
capability of rebalancing away from
Russian gas and once this is done in a
structural manner it will be Russia
bearing the longer term cost of the war
he decided to start against Ukraine
really good to talk to you Simone many
thanks indeed for being with us once
again Simone Talia Pietra there in
Brussels
the cost of living has been rising ever
since pandemic lockdowns disrupted
Global Supply chains and caused Panic
buying in the supermarkets now Russia's
invasion of Ukraine is pushing the price
of almost everything from energy to
wheat further up inflation is near
double-digit territory in many of the
world's biggest economies a level not
seen in close to half a century in
Indonesia for example the price of
petrol and Diesel went up about 30
percent last week after the government
cut subsidies not a serious Jessica
Washington reports from Jakarta
from 7am to 7 PM sarawako rides through
the streets of the Indonesian Capital he
became a motorbike Taxi Driver after
losing his job at an Exhibition Center
during the pandemic he is one of
millions of people battling to make ends
meet after the government can't fuel
subsidies
the money I make is already not enough
often I don't eat lunch just so I can
send the money on my children's needs
fuel prices went up by about 30 percent
with subsidized petrol increasing from
around 51 cents to 67 cents per liter
and Diesel going up from 35 to 46 cents
per liter
soaring Global oil and gas prices as
well as the depreciation of the local
currency tripled the state's subsidy
budget to 34 billion dollars
the government says it's reallocating
some funds to social grants with 20
million low-income households said to
receive around 10 a month until the end
of the year
for many it's an inadequate solution
the Cash Aid is like candy totally
useless we want them to lower the price
of fuel down unions and students have
led protests in several cities
around the country the message is clear
many people worried about
of living and those concerns have been
exacerbated by this latest policy change
some economists are also critical of the
decision
all of the society all of the consumers
level hit by the increase of the fuel
price and at the same time the minimum
wage in Indonesia is only increased by
one percent so inflations versus the
income of the ordinary citizen in
Indonesia is not ketchup
higher fuel costs have a knock-on effect
essential Goods become more expensive
because Logistics expenses increase
a worrying Prospect for Artie who is
already skipping meals
before the price hike life was already
hard now it's even more difficult
he spends an extra dollar and a half on
fuel every day it's an expense that he
like millions of Indonesians cannot
afford
joining us now from London is Paul
Donovan who is Chief Economist at UBS
Bank Global wealth management Paul good
to have you with us on counting the cost
once again we've been talking a lot on
the program today about Europe's energy
crisis are people really going to have
to choose between staying warm and
eating is the 375 billion dollar relief
package that's been proposed going to be
enough
uh I think the package is going to go a
long way to mitigating the costs to
individuals uh and perhaps a little bit
less as far as cost of businesses are
concerned that there is some assistance
there of course this is not a a precise
science it depends how cold the winter
is it depends on how much people are
able to cut back on energy consumption
uh and of course the bigger the shock in
terms of limiting gas supplies limiting
your power generation the bigger the
reaction that you get here people will
turn down thermostats they will work
from home which is a big energy saving
uh Drive less frequently another big
energy saving so it's a very very
imprecise calculation I'm afraid of
course inflation biting everywhere but
it hits hardest in the developing world
what has been the impact of inflation
there President Putin says that
Ukrainian grain exports uh that were
done under the deal that President
erdogan uh brokered a helping richer
Nations at the expense of the developing
world is he right
no I think that's an overly simplistic
analysis to put it politely
um what we've got to remember of course
is that agricultural Commodities don't
have a huge impact directly on inflation
in developed countries because food in
developed countries isn't really food
food in a developed country is is nearly
all labor costs and the agricultural
Commodities view that the price the
farmer gets is a very small part the
issue here is that when we see Rising
agricultural commodity prices that is
something which hits less developed
economies a lot more significantly
because in a less developed economy food
is effectively a lot closer to the
farmer it's also worth bearing in mind
we were going to have a food price
problem this year because it's a la nina
weather system this year and climate
change has been making the La Nina
effect more and more destructive over
time so you know the effects of the
droughts in the west coast of the United
States the disruption to the monsoon
season in India and Pakistan those are
things which were going to happen anyway
have had a significant impact on
agricultural commodity prices war in
Ukraine has made things worse but this
was going to be a high food price here
anyway okay let's let's take in uh China
let's take in the US here and uh
interest rates a broad brush question
here for you Paul are we likely to see a
global recession I know certain
economies in certain parts of the world
are predicting recessions others aren't
though
uh I think a global slowdown will happen
that is to say we would be expecting
growth to slow this year anyway because
the uh frantic pace of consumption we
had after the global pandemic was
starting to fade uh with the United
States slowing down as it is is doing
and with Europe slowing down I mean
there you've got the the largest and the
second largest economy in the world so
of course you're going to get a global
slowdown I think a recession which you
know there's no proper definition of
what a recession is but a a recession
defined as a period of significantly
below Trend growth that's clearly a risk
but I think it is very much a risk case
and the signals that we're seeing from
the United States for example are still
showing us that the consumer is prepared
to support the economy and prevent us
going into some kind of economic slump
China's economy is weak but China's
economy is quite insular so you know
what happens in China doesn't
necessarily have a huge Global impact
the European economy is where we've got
the most uncertainty of course but
overall I think it's slowed down rather
than slump at a very brief answer I need
from you here Paul because we're almost
out of time um how long before inflation
begins to ease
it's already easing in the United States
in Europe it depends on the precise
nature of government policies but fairly
soon always good to talk to you Paul
many thanks indeed Paul Donovan there at
UBS Global Wealth Management
and that's our show for this week don't
forget if you want to comment on
anything that you've seen you can get in
touch with us I'm at a Finnegan on
Twitter use the hashtag ajctc when you
do please or drop us a line counting the
cost at altazira.net is our email
address there's plenty more for you
online as always at altazira.com CTC
that takes you straight to our page and
there you'll find individual reports
links and entire episodes for you to
catch up on but that is it for this
edition of counting the cost I'm Adrian
Finnegan from the whole team thanks for
being with us the news on Al Jazeera is
next foreign